.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
HERE WE ARE ONLY EIGHT DAYS TO
GO, TONIGHT HERSCHEL WALKER THE
WERE ALL JOIN US STRAIGHT AHEAD.
THESE RACES WILL DETERMINE THE
BALANCE OF POWER AND THE UNITS
IN IT AND IT MATTERS TO ALL OF
YOU.
PLUS WE WILL BRING YOU THE
LATEST POLLS AND THE ANALYSIS A
REPUBLICANS CONTINUE TO SEARCH
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NOW EVEN WASHINGTON STATE IS
VERY MUCH IN PLAY.
TO GET THIS RIGHT HERE.
POLITICS JUST MOVED IT INTO THE
TOSSUP COLUMN.
THE ONLY THING THAT DOES MATTER
IS WHAT HAPPENS ON ELECTION DAY.
TAKE NOTHING FOR GRANTED.
EVERYBODY HAS TO VOTE AND
EVERYBODY HAS TO PARTICIPATE AT
THIS POINT, DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING INCREASINGLY DESPERATE.
AS PER USUAL, AS WE PREDICTED.
THAT WE SEE EVERY SINGLE
ELECTION YEAR.
I SAID AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THIS ELECTION YEAR.
THAT HAS FIZZLED.
THE DOBBS DECISION, AND THAT AN
MANY WAYS HAS BACKFIRED SINCE S
MANY DEMOCRATS WANT ZERO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION MEANIN
THAT THEY SUPPORT ABORTION UP T
THE MOMENT OF BIRTH.
THAT IS OUT OF TOUCH WITH MOST
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REPUBLICANS ARE RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, ISLAMIC PHOBIC,
TRANS PHOBIC, YOU WANT DIRTY AI
AND WATER AND YOU WANT TO THROW
GRANNY AND GRANDPA OFF A CLIFF.
YOU WANT TO ELIMINATE SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE.
AFTER TWO HORRIFIC YEARS, AFTER
THE MOST INCOMPETENT PRESIDENT
IN DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
THEY HAVE NOTHING LEFT.
DEMOCRATS ARE TURNING TO THE
ANOINTED ONE, HE IS BACK AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO HOPE AND PRA
THAT HE CAN HELP DRIVE HOME
THEIR LINE AND SAVE THEM FROM
MIDTERM SHELLACKING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY WANT TO CUT SOCIAL
SECURITY, AND MEDICARE, AND THE
GIVE SOME MORE TAX BREAKS TO TH
WEALTHY.
THE REASON I NOTEPADS AGENDA.
IF THERE WAS AN ASTEROID HEADED
TOWARD EARTH, ITS CRIMINAL LAND
IN LIKE TWO WEEKS.
IF YOU WENT TO THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS AND SAID WHAT YOU WANT T
DO, WE NEED A TAX BREAK FOR THE
WEALTHY, THAT'S GOING TO HELP.
>> IF THAT ASTEROID WAS HEADED
TOWARD EARTH, YOU WOULD SAY
DONALD TRUMP BROUGHT A.
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IS PLANNING TO CUT
MEDICARE OR SOCIAL SECURITY.
DEMOCRATS NO LONGER SEEM TO
VALUE TRUTH IN LOGIC UNLESS IT
HELPS THEM POLITICALLY.
ACCORDING TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
INFLATION WAS ONLY TRANSITORY W
HAVE ZERO INFLATION AT A POINT
WHEN IT WAS A 40 WHEN YOUR HIGH.
GAS PRICES ARE DOWN.
>> THE BORDER IS SECURE, AND AS
NEW YORK GOVERNOR CLAIMS,
AMERICA'S VIOLENT CRIME SEARCH
AS NOTHING MORE THAN A VAST
RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY IT'S NOT
TRUE, IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
DON'T BELIEVE YOUR VERY EYES
WHEN YOU WATCH THE NEWS EVERY
NIGHT PRIDE.
>> THESE ARE MASTER MANIPULATORS
.
THEY HAVE THIS CONSPIRACY GOING
ALL ACROSS AMERICA TO TRY TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT IT
DEMOCRATIC STATES ARE AS SAFE,
GUESS WHAT, THEY'RE NOT ONLY
ELECTION DENIERS, THEY ARE DATA
DENIERS.
>> HERE IS SOME DATA FOR HER
LAST YEAR NEW YORK CITY HAD THE
HIGHEST MURDER RATE AND A DECAD
THE MOST SHOOTINGS IN 15 YEARS,
CARJACKINGS GOVERNOR ARE UP OVE
200 PERCENT.
MAJOR CRIME IS UP 36 PERCENT.
RETAIL THEFT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
ARREST PEOPLE THAT STEAL LESS
THAN $1,000, THAT IS SURGING
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
CRIME IS BEGGING EVERYWHERE.
11 OF THE 15 DEADLIEST PLACES T
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY ARE RUN BY
DEMOCRATS, NOT BY REPUBLICANS.
THE LEFT IN THEIR DEFUND
MOVEMENT HAS WREAKED HAVOC ON
MAJOR CITIES AND TOWNS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE HORRIFIC
ATTACK ON SPEAKER PELOSI'S
HUSBAND PAUL.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS HE WAS
ASSAULTED WITH A HAMMER INSIDE
HIS OWN HOME BY AN INTRUDER
LOOKING FOR NANCY COME WITH THE
ASSAILANT WE KNOW TO BE AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT IS HYPER
PARANOID, PRO- ACTIVIST WHO
ALLEGEDLY LIVES AND A STORAGE
SHED AND BELIEVES IN
CONSPIRACIES.
ATTACKS LIKE THIS SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
AS I'VE SAID HER OVER IN OVER
AGAIN.
EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL AND THEI
FAMILIES MUST BE PROTECTED.
WE PROVIDE A PRIVATE JET FOR TH
SPEAKER PELOSI TO TRAVEL TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND BACK.
I WOULD ASSUME FOR SECURITY
REASONS, WHY WOULDN'T WE
SUPPRESS SUPPLY HER SECRET
SERVICE PROTECTION.
AFTER THE VICE PRESIDENT, IT IS
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE THAT
WOULD BE IN LINE TO BE PRESIDEN
FRAID THIS IS NOT POLITICAL,
EVERYONE DESERVES TO BE SAFE,
EVERYONE.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY ON THE LEFT
WANT THIS TO BE POLITICAL THEY
WANT VOTERS TO BELIEVE THAT THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO ATTACKED
PAUL PELOSI IS REPRESENTATIVE O
CONSERVATIVES IN AMERICA.
THEY ARE EVEN ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF PREVENTING
VIOLENCE.
OF COURSE THEY WERE SINGING A
VERY DIFFERENT TUNE REMEMBER
WHEN THAT BERNIE SANDERS SUPER
FAN SHOT UP A BASEBALL FIELD
FULL OF REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS AN
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER JUST THIS
YEAR THE ALL BUT IGNORED THE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT AGAINST
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CAVANAUGH.
WHEN SENATOR RAND PAUL WAS
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED, MANY ON TH
LEFT THEY JUST MOCKED IT, NANCY
PELOSI'S OWN DAUGHTER EVEN
PRAISE THE ATTACK AND THE MEDIA
MOB THOUGHT IT WAS HYSTERICAL.
A QUICK REMINDER.
>> KNEW DETAILS TODAY ON THE
INCIDENT THAT LEFT SENATOR RAND
PAUL WITH SIX BROKEN RIBS.
THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF MY FAVORIT
STORIES.
CLEARLY SENATOR PAUL IS STILL
STRUGGLING FOR IT.
>> IS SOME KIND OF QUOTE ISSUE
AROUND THE PROPERTY BECAUSE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD FRACAS.
IF I EVER MEET RAND PAUL'S
NEIGHBOR I'M GOING TO HUG HIM
AND BY HIM AS MANY DRINKS AS HE
CAN CONSUME.
TO GET MANY IN THE MEDIA MOB
HAVE THE GALL TO BASH PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR WAITING TWO WHOLE DAY
BEFORE CONDEMNING THE ATTACK.
I THOUGHT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
HEAR FROM MR. TRUMP.
NOW THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM MR.
TRUMP.
HE CALLED THE HORRIBLE THING AN
ALSO CONDEMNED THE VIOLENT CRIM
WAVE IN SAN FRANCISCO, CHICAGO
AND OTHER MAJOR CITIES.
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T LIKE THAT PART.
THE ONLY VALUE THAT TRUTH IF IT
HELPS THEM POLITICALLY.
IF THE VIOLENCE, THEY CAN USE I
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES, LET'S
TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU MIGHT RECALL AND THE SUMMER
OF 202574 RIOTS, DOZENS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, WE HAD BRICKS, ROCKS
BOTTLES, MOLOTOV COCKTAILS
THROWN AT POLICE OFFICERS.
WE HAD BILLIONS IN PROPERTY
DAMAGE, IN MOST DEMOCRATS WERE
EITHER SILENT OR LIED TO US AND
TOLD US THEY WERE MOSTLY
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
WHERE WERE THEY THEN?
BY THE WAY, PAUL PELOSI WAS THE
VICTIM OF A DERANGED INDIVIDUAL.
IT SAD, BUT IT'S HAPPENING IN
CITY AFTER CITY AND TOWN AFTER
TOWN AND IT'S BECOMING
INCREASINGLY WALLACE FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF DEMOCRATI
POLICIES.
WHEN YOU STOP PROSECUTING CRIMES
, WHEN YOU LET VIOLENT
FELONS OUT OF JAIL, WHEN YOU
PREVENT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FROM DEPORTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, WHEN YOU EXCUSE AWA
VIOLENT RIOTS LIKE WE SAW AND
THE SUMMER OF 2020, WHEN YOU
BELIEVE IN DEFUND AND DISMANTLE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS, WHEN YOU
COME UP WITH THESE IDIOTIC
NOBELS LAWS, GUESS WHAT, CRIME
GOES UP IN COMMUNITIES AND TOWN
IN CITIES AND PEOPLE SUFFER.
WHILE ABIDING AMERICANS ARE
VICTIMIZED EXCEPT WE DON'T KNOW
THEIR NAMES FROM IT THEY DON'T
GET THE COVERAGE THAT PAUL
PELOSI GOT ANYBODY THAT GETS
HURT BECAUSE OF THESE BAD
POLICIES, AT WHAT POINT DO WE
BLAME THE POLITICIANS THAT PUT
THESE IDIOTIC IMBECILIC POLICIE
IN PLACE.
THIS CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE
INCLUDING THE GREAT STATE OF
GEORGIA WHICH STACY ABRAMS IS
THREONINE TO UPEND THE SECURITY.
THEY SUGGESTED THE POLICE IN
GEORGIA ARE RACIST GOOD OLD BOYS
.
>> MEN AND WOMEN OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOW WHO IS GOING T
BE WITH THEM AND HE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR BACK.
THAT IS ME.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE THE
ENDORSEMENT OF 107 SHERIFFS
AROUND THE STATE FAIR.
>> AS I POINTED OUT BEFORE, I'M
NOT A MEMBER OF THE GOOD OF BOY
CLUB.
I DON'T HAVE 107 SHERIFFS WHO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE BLACK
PEOPLE OF THE STREETS, WHO WANT
TO BE ABLE TO GO WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILI